this our club
[Applause]
what's up guys web community such a from
jumping from what we do now am I went
from
lessard with have trouble with lux want
you guys again
and
[Music]
[Applause]
ok
[Music]
what a nice counter to
[  Music]
can you contact me
[Music]
what
hoo hoo hoo huxley before this
[Music]
[Applause]
well how you tomorrow 2
[Music]
oh
and
om
[Music]
how many other
yes well important
[Music]
and
okay we'll definitely visit hit will be
a mini make a means
[Music]
bur-o-class the wat in the morning torah me
net very very very very
[Music]
freezer [ __ ] good
from sir 06:00
just for me  lets confused hi
thank you are coming back
with
two pencils and what
ever
hey
[Music]
how
fell upon to buy and sell lucky day
fine 50 g flex fortune guys camping
yogis they got him subscribe yeah
and two atps videos
holds very real
[Music]
normal